[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins et
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
olivier maintenant détenu depuis huit
mois quelles sont les nouvelles les
nouvelles y en a très peu
malheureusement elles sont coupés de
tout il n'est pas dans un hôtel
capturé avec un téléphone et il peut
nous donner des nouvelles non à votre
avis quelles sont ses conditions de
détention aujourd'hui c'est sûr elles
sont très difficiles parce que les
anciens otages ont que nous
le racontait qu'il a des conditions de
vie qui sont très rudimentaires et très
dur j'espère vraiment de tout mon coeur
qui qui ressemble notre énergie moi
j'essaye de faire de mon mieux bien sûr
tout simplement pour qu'ils m'entendent
parce que c'est ça mon travail c'est la
france aime valley où la france ou le
mali qui vont libérer olivier g pas ce
pouvoir de libérer mais par contre j'ai
le devoir de mobilisation je ne
l'abandonnerai part je ne laisserai pas
[Musique]
plus de deux cent six mille nouveaux cas
au moins de 24 heures en france pour
tenter d'endiguer l'épidémie le port du
masque devient obligatoire en extérieur
dès demain dans de nombreuses villes du
pays elle c'est le cas à paris c'est
dans une majorité des villes d'île de
france c'est le cas aussi à lyon et
bourg départements sont concernés comme
la loire atlantique et la charente
maritime une amende de 135 euros est
prévue pour les fraudeurs à noter aussi
que les foires les parcs d'attraction et
les autres ne seront pas concernés par
les limitations de jauge
[Musique]
plus d'un millions de contaminés au co
vide par jour
le cap a été franchi la semaine dernière
une augmentation fulgurante des cas qui
met encore plus la pression sur les
systèmes de santé sur l'équilibré
économique des pays en espagne les
festivités pour le 31 décembre sont
pratiquement tout annuler en allemagne
les discothèques resteront fermées et
les rassemblements de plus de dix
personnes sont interdits
joe biden et vadimir poutine vont
s'entretenir ce soit au téléphone au
programme de la conversation la
situation à la frontière ukrainienne
c'est le deuxième appel entre les deux
présidents au moins d'un mois pour
trouver des solutions à la crise a le
président américain compte proposer une
voie diplomatique quand le président
russe lui espère venir à bout des
tensions par la négociation
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
si vous nous rejoignez sur rt france
depuis hier les députés planchent sur le
projet de loi du pass vaccinale et sera
votée à lundi prochain par l'assemblée
nationale un examen qui doit aller plus
vite puisque le gouvernement espère le
mettre en place dès le 15 janvier
prochain une mesure pour tenter
d'endiguer l'augmentation fulgurante des
cas dans le pays près de deux cent six
mille cas ces dernières 24 heures pour
contrer le virus le port du masque en
extérieur fait aussi son retour dans de
nombreuses villes du pays et ce dès
demain ça sera le cas à paris et dans
une grande partie des villes d'île de
france a lyon aussi chez dans le
département de loire atlantique
les fraudeurs s'exposent à une amende de
135 euros retour justement sur la
situation et les contours du nouveau
pass vaccinale avec yamina benguigui da
impasse vaccinale pour remplacer
l'actuel passe sanitaires le projet
législatif porté par le gouvernement a
été validé par la commission des lois
dans la nuit de mercredi à jeudi il doit
passer devant l'assemblée et le sénat
dans les prochains jours un calendrier
accéléré par des chiffres alarmants
l'augmentation continuelle du nombre de
contaminations dans le pays ce sont des
chiffres qui donnent le vertige il y à
208 milles français qui ont été
diagnostiqués positifs au co vide au
cours des 24 dernières heures j'ai fait
un rapide calcul avant de vous rejoindre
ça veut dire que vingt-quatre heures sur
vingt-quatre jour et nuit toutes les
deux secondes toutes les secondes par
dont toutes les secondes d'un pays de
français plus de deux français sont
diagnostiqués positifs au cours d'un
virus exigé pour toute personne âgée de
plus de 12 ans ce nouveau sésame
permettra l'accès au bar restaurant à
l'ensemble des activités de loisirs ou
encore d'effectuer des déplacements
inter régionaux en train bus ou avions
autant de cas de figure mal perçue par
l'opposition dont plusieurs membres ont
tenté en vain de supprimer l'article
relatif aux passeports finale lors du
passage en commission la vaccination et
nous en sommes convaincus un moyen sûr
de lutter contre l'épidémie en revanche
les passes n'ont rien de scientifique
ils sont une manière spécifique de
gouverner le pays en faisant du vaccin
critères d'accès à certains lieux du
quotidien emmanuel macron et le
gouvernement n'ont cessé de mentir en
connaissance de cause pour imposer leurs
stratégies perdantes du tout vaccinal le
vaccin empêchant ni de contracter ni de
transmettre le virus j'appelle à
renoncer au pass and i ter vaccinale le
nouvel outil
s'accompagnera également d'un
renforcement des contrôles sur tout site
où le passé et exiger une pièce
d'identité pourra être demandé les
détenteurs d'un faux document s'exposent
à de lourdes sanctions
mille euros damende dès la première
infraction constatée une sentence
équivalente pour le professionnel en cas
d'absence de contrôle des clients
mais le pass vaccinale ne sera pas
exigée par tous lors d'une réunion
politique par exemple aucune obligation
seul un test pcr ou un test antigénique
négatif un schéma vaccinal complet ou un
certificat de rétablissement à la suite
d'une contamination aux covit 19
pourront être demandées aux participants
pour les français nombreux à se faire
tester en cette période de fêtes ce
projet divise je viens de voir là à
l'instant que le nom de contamination
aujourd'hui de 200 milles c'était 100
milles à noël donc je pense que le plus
vite aux magies et
et on
la vaccination
8on votre liberté
face à des chiffres record de 108 mille
cas en 24 heures le gouvernement
souhaite faire appliquer le pass
vaccinale au plus vite une entrée en
vigueur est prévue dès le 15 janvier et
le projet de loi sur le passé
actionnelle fait réagir depuis déjà
quelques temps pour notre éditorialiste
à nicolas vidal l absentéisme des
députés lors du vote des lois pourraient
poser problème dans ce cas précis
il faut se poser la question de
l'existence du conseil d'état et de sa
légitimité puisqu'il est chargé un
moment donné des trois moment donné
quand un contre pouvoir y en avoir et on
va le voir elle contre pouvoir ils sont
en train de tomber les uns après les
autres ici pour ça que c'est très très
grave donc qu'est ce qui va se passer
ils ont conseil d'état hier la
commission et le lundi 3 janvier dès
potron minet bien sûr s'en passe à 8
heures il va y avoir le texte à
l'assemblée donc on va se régaler parce
qu'on va voir on va voir quoi on va voir
combien durera deux députés l'assemblée
nationale rappelez-vous soit le loi du
passé ni terre la premier article
deuxième article il n'y avait même pas
150 160 députés donc ça ça pose vraiment
des questions donc à une nouvelle
question qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
questions dans cette politique telle ans
l'absentéisme pro gbagbo ou pas des
députés alors certains avaient fait le
choix de la couardise au premier vote
finalement loi pas sanitaire pour éviter
bien entendu d'appuyer sur le buzzer
qu'ils ont face à eux le député à deux
boutons et c'est assez simple comme
histoire et donc est là qu est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que c'est
absolument l'effondrement l'effondrement
du contrôle du pouvoir exécutif
le retour du port du masque à
l'extérieur dans presque toute l'île de
france c'est pour demain décision prise
suite à l'explosion du nombre de quatre
kovy jonna lee dans la région parisienne
sur fond de variants mikron une décision
accueillie entre fatalisme et
compréhension un peu de déception
également écouter justement ces quelques
réactions dans les rues de saint denis
franchement pour moi
je comprends pas pourquoi on donne
obligé de porter le masque qui ont fait
déjà les tests on a un troisième dose
qui ont obligé des le fait est que en
tant de gens malades qui pensent qu'ils
vont respecter ce qu'il me faut te
prenais pas le choix
pour éviter les contaminations avec
l'eau micron tous est nécessaire
compte tenu des circonstances sanitaire
c'est impératif voilà pour que
symboliquement les gens comprennent que
on est dans une situation difficile
regarde mon argent j'ai peur pour mon
argent j'ai pas beaucoup d'argent je
mets le mas parce que j'ai pas eu peur
d'avoir à 135 euros sur mon dos et alors
que les jauges vont s'appliquer dès
lundi dans les salles de spectacle et
les foires les salons et les eaux ne
seront quant à eux pas concernés elles
ce sont des endroits où on circule
justifie du ministre du travail a pas de
jauge prévu non plus lors des meetings
politiques
rassemblement national et la france 1
soumises ont confirmé hier qu'il ferait
campagne sans aucune restriction
supplémentaire un sujet de sandra
tshilombo
ce lundi le gouvernement a annoncé le
retour des jauges pour les grands
événements de 1000 personnes maximum en
intérieur et 5000 personnes maximum en
extérieur sauf dans les meetings
politiques
dispensé de passes sanitaires les
réunions politiques ne sont pas non plus
concernés par les jauges une décision
validée en mai dernier par le conseil
constitutionnel
elle figure également dans le projet de
loi vigilance sanitaire du 9 novembre
l'exercice du culte d'une part et les
activités politiques et électorales
d'autre part sont soumises à des
dispositions spécifiques dans notre
droit constitutionnel qui leur assure
une protection encore plus forte
plusieurs candidats ont maintenu leurs
meetings en début d'année marine le pen
le 15 janvier au parc des expositions de
reims jean luc mélenchon le 16 janvier
au parc des expositions de nantes
malgré l'absence de jauge les partis
politiques entendent montrer l'exemple
les règles constitutionnelles ne
permettent pas de fixer des jauges aux
réunions politiques mais évidemment la
majorité présidentielle s'imposera de
respecter les jauges fixé dans tous ces
événements face à ce qu'il considère
comme une injustice
plusieurs chanteurs comme grand corps
malade ou encore julien doré ont annoncé
transformer leurs concerts en meeting
politique
je suis donc candidat aux élections
présidentielles tous mes meetings sont
maintenus roselyne bachelot s'est voulu
rassurante et a réitéré l'engagement de
l'état dans le soutien des artistes
depuis le début de cette crise le monde
de la culture fait preuve de courage et
de responsabilité
et l'état va demeurer aux côtés de ceux
qui seront impactés par ces nouvelles
mesures circonscrite dont le temps est
adaptée à l'évolution de la situation
sanitaire
et si la situation sanitaire est
critique en france elle l'est aussi dans
les prisons 400 détenus elle sur les 70
milles dans le pays serait positif au
coronavirus selon le ministère de la
santé les surveillants ont eux aussi
sont particulièrement touchés pour
l'instant les parloirs sont suspendus
dans les centres pénitenciers fortement
impacté le port du masque est
obligatoire en dehors des cellules avec
la propagation les syndicats alertent
sur le risque de dysfonctionnement
wilfrid forgues secrétaire national du
fap unsa justice déplore justement un
manque d'anticipation de gouvernement
aujourd'hui ce sont des mesures
finalement de bon sens c'est-à-dire à la
fois remettre en place les dispositifs
de séparation au niveau des parloirs ce
qui était dieu a lieu avant c'est à dire
avec un plexiglas on limite les
activités des mouvements au strict
minimum et également on puisse au niveau
des personnels bénéficier des masques
ffp2 puisqu'a priori il semble être
beaucoup plus efficace puisque beaucoup
plus filtrants et qu'également les
mesures concernant le télétravail pour
l'ensemble des personnels dont les
missions sont éligibles qu'ils puissent
en bénéficier à hauteur minimum de trois
jours et non pas parce que souhaite
faire aujourd'hui l'administration
pénitentiaire notamment avec les
personnels d'insertion et probation
puisque eux ne seront limitées
finalement qu'à deux jours par semaine
et non pas trois comme le souhaite le
gouvernement
elle avait des festivités pour le 31
décembre la situation sanitaire dans le
monde est extrêmement tendue le cap du
million d' infecté au coronavirus par
jour a été franchi la semaine dernière
les pays cherchent à l' équilibre entre
santé et économie alors comment les pays
européens affronte cette nouvelle vague
en période de fêtes tour d'horizon avec
adrien fonteneau et walid ben ali
à quelques heures du nouvel an le
variant mikron submerge les pays
européens avec 28 1828 nouveaux cas
record en 24 heures la grèce et son
système de santé sont sous pression un
niveau de contamination qui entraîne des
nouvelles restrictions initialement
prévu le 3 janvier les mesures entrent
en vigueur ce jeudi stéphane cindric à
l'utilisation d'une protection plus
élevées est recommandée dans les
environnements surpeuplés les
établissements accueillant du monde
devront fermer à minuit les tables
n'auront pas compter plus de six
personnes avec une distanciation social
entre les tables
cas pareils pachuca ça passe l'autre
annonce concerne l'annulation des
manifestations ou rassemblements publics
pour les fêtes du 31 décembre
même constat au danemark avec de
nombreux tests pcr effectué après noël
et un record de contamination
établi à 23 1228 car en 24 heures côté
allemand les réunions privées de plus de
10 personnes vaccinées ou guéris sont
interdites pour les non vaccinés seuls
deux membres deux foyers différents sont
autorisés
rhône s'il vous plaît célébrée en très
petit groupe et ne vous mettez pas en
danger les uns les autres car le chiffre
de l'incidence actuelle des cas signalés
ne rend pas compte du danger dans lequel
nous nous trouvons actuellement
mais la tendance européenne n'est pas
correct rictions malgré près de cent
mille cas sur une journée l'espagne
devient l'un des premiers pays à réduire
la durée de quarantaine des personnes
contaminées
l' isolement des cas contacts non
vaccinés passe de dix à sept jours et
l'ensemble des restrictions se veut plus
modérée nous sommes passés de 10 jours à
une réduction à sept jours pour ces
personnes positives au co vide ou en cas
contact avec un cas positif je tiens à
dire que cette proposition a été
approuvée à l'unanimité par tous les
membres de la commission de santé
publique en belgique enfin la culture
l'a emporté la justice a contraint le
gouvernement à annuler la fermeture des
salles de spectacles et cinéma côté
contamination les chiffres ont baissé de
25 %
et 6 et le vario micro n'était moins
dangereux qu'ils pouvaient favoriser
l'immunité collective
elle s'est en tout cas la stratégie
d'israël qui a stoppé sa campagne pour
la quatrième dose de vaccin et les
scientifiques sur place espère récolter
davantage de données sur ce variant
avant que potentiellement recommencer la
campagne vaccinale israël qui a reçu sa
première livraison de pilules anti
qu'ovide fader pour être efficace le
traitement dont intervenir dans les cinq
jours suivant les premiers symptômes il
permettrait de réduire les
hospitalisations de 88% les décès chez
les personnes à risque
la dîmière poutine et joe biden
s'entretiennent par téléphone ce soir à
quelques heures de leur entretien est
les deux présidents ont affirmé leur
volonté de dialoguer pour résoudre la
crise à la frontière ukrainienne elle
c'est la deuxième fois que le président
russe et le président américain
s'entretiennent en moins à d'un mois sur
le sujet est la voie diplomatique et le
dialogue semble être la volonté des deux
hommes est les précisions de notre
correspondante à moscou
maëlys d'estrées
c'est à l'initiative du président russe
qu aura lieu cet entretien téléphonique
avec joe biden moins d'un mois après la
première visioconférence entre les deux
dirigeants le kremlin souhaite ainsi
préparer les négociations russo
américaines sur l'ukraine et la sécurité
en europe qui auront lieu ce 10 janvier
à genève
depuis la dernière conversation la
russie comme promis à formuler sa
position qui a été énoncé dans les
projets des deux documents qui ont été
portées à l'attention de washington et
d'un certain nombre de capitales
européennes
et donc maintenant bien sûr de notre
point de vue du point de vue du
président poutine il faut mener une
autre conversation téléphonique qui
précéderait le début des négociations
susmentionnés
toute négociation quelle qu'elle soit
nous somme n'est qu'avec un seul
objectif parvenir à un compromis en
tenant compte des positions de principe
des uns et des autres
en fait des revendications russe
l'interdiction de tout élargissement
futur de l'otan vers l'est ainsi que la
fin des manoeuvres militaires
occidentales près des frontières de la
russie la maison blanche veut elle que
les troupes russes s'éloigne de la
frontière ukrainienne bien entendu les
déplacements de nos forces armées sur
notre territoire son autre prérogative
exclusive
yves vous savez qu'il existe différentes
opinions à ce sujet notamment parmi les
représentants des autorités ukrainiennes
il dit au contraire qu'il ne constate
aucune accumulation extraordinaire de
troupes russes près de la frontière ce
qui provoquerait l'inquiétude du côté
ukrainien il faut prendre en compte de
telles déclarations aussi dans ses voeux
de nouvel an adressé ce mercredi au
président américain la lumière footing
s'est dit convaincu qu'un dialogue
constructif et fondé sur le respect
mutuel était possible entre moscou et
washington
et aux états unis quelques mois des
élections de mi-mandat la popularité de
joe biden est en berne et selon un
récent sondage une majorité des
républicains regretterai toujours donald
trump sept militants sur dix estiment
que son élection a été volé une enquête
qui révèle aussi des divergences sur
l'assaut du capitole les précisions à
washington de notre correspondante homme
abonné aux etats-unis la situation n'a
pas véritablement changé depuis la
dernière élection présidentielle une
étude d'une université du massachusetts
montre l'étendue des divisions au sein
du peuple américain ils sont par exemple
71 % parmi les électeurs républicains à
considérer joe biden comme un président
illégitime ils sont encore une large
majorité parmi ces électeurs a estimé
qu'il ya eu des irrégularités lors du
dernier scrutin présidentiel et puis
concernant la journée du 6 janvier 2021
et les événements au capitole enquête
montre là encore une différence de
perception entre les démocrates et les
républicains
chacun accusant des personnalités
différentes pour leurs responsabilités
et alors que 86 % des démocrates
soutiennent les enquêtes en cours dans
ce dossier plus d'un républicain sur
deux s'y opposent en fait l'un des
aspects les plus intéressants de ce
sondage c'est qu'il montre que ces
chiffres n'ont quasiment pas évolué en
l'espace d'un an un aspect canalise l'un
des auteurs de cette enquête écouter
alors que nous concluons une année qui a
vu se produire une attaque choquante sur
le capitole des états unis ainsi que des
affirmations persistante et sans
fondement la part de l'ancien président
et de ses flagorneurs sur le fait que
l'élection présidentielle de 2020 a été
volé nous continuons de voir les
républicains et les démocrates vivre
dans deux réalités diamétralement
opposées cet état des lieux de l'opinion
américaine est riche d'enseignements
alors qu'en 2022 se tiendront les
élections de mi-mandat des élections au
cours desquelles donald trump prendra
certainement beaucoup de place du côté
républicain le positionnement vis-à-vis
à des propos de l'ancien président sur
la dernière élection sera source de
controverse surtout que les électeurs
indécis semblent majoritairement
hermétique à la théorie de la fraude
électorale et puis du côté démocrate
certains alerte déjà comme l'a montré et
l'élection du gouverneur en virginie la
stratégie qui vise à concentrer les
attaques sur donald trump pourra
certainement ses limites en tout cas ce
scrutin ne devrait pas atténuer la
fracture au sein du peuple américain qui
semble quasiment irréparable sur ces
sujets
la fermeture d'un site d'information
hong kong s'est coulé beaucoup d'encre
l'union européenne le canada et les
etats-unis condamnent cette disparition
du paysage médiatique de stand news la
chine elle dénonce des critiques
irresponsables des pays occidentaux
retour sur cette affaire avec elle à
medjahed
le médiastin news a dû annoncer lui-même
sa fermeture ce mercredi un point final
forcé après une opération de la police
cette personne du site d'information
dont le directeur ont été arrêtés au
lendemain de cette intervention deux des
interpellés ont été inculpés il s'agit
du rédacteur en chef patrick l'âme et de
son prédécesseur leur demande de liberté
sous caution a été refusée les autorités
hongkongaises les accuse de publication
séditieuse
par exemple ils ont décrit des
manifestants à hong kong comme portés
disparus ou violet rappelez vous c'était
après la mise en oeuvre de la loi sur la
sécurité nationale donc longtemps après
les manifestations de 2019
ce sont des allégations malfaisante sans
aucune base factuelle et stay news les
inclut dans ses articles stand news a
aussi été visés par une série de
perquisitions le média et les domiciles
de ses employés ont été fouillés des
documents des téléphones des ordinateurs
et près de 57 milles euros en espèces
ont été saisis par les forces de l'ordre
l'entreprise éditrice du site best
pencil est également poursuivi les
autorités ont gelé 7 millions d'euros
d'avoirs de cette société
ces actions sont des actions
d'application de la loi ces actions
n'ont rien à voir avec la soi disant
suppression de la liberté de la presse
ou la soi-disant suppression de la
démocratie comme certains le disent
[Musique]
une réponse à peine voilée aux critiques
des occidentaux et notamment de l'union
européenne et des états unis en
réduisant au silence des médias
indépendants
la chine et les autorités locales sape
la crédibilité et la viabilité de hong
kong pekin les autorités hongkongaises
doivent cesser de s'en prendre aux
médias libres et indépendants de hong
kong devant la presse le porte-parole de
la diplomatie chinoise a répondu
directement cette attaque pékin demande
à washington de cesser de s'ingérer dans
les affaires de hong kong
nous demandons une vraie loi aux états
unis de lever toutes les sanctions
allant entre des personnes chinoises et
de cesser de se mêler des affaires de
hong kong et de s'ingérer dans la
politique intérieure de la chine la
chine continuera à prendre toutes les
mesures nécessaires pour défendre ses
intérêts nationaux dans le respect de la
loi
et une nouvelle affaire qu'il ne devrait
pas arranger les relations déjà très
tendues entre pékin et washington
stand news et le deuxième média
indépendant à disparaître cette année à
hong kong en juin dernier le quotidien
apple daily avait lui aussi mis la clé
sous la porte après l'arrestation de ses
dirigeants et le gel de ses actifs
et nouvelle journée de mobilisation au
soudan toujours coupées du monde après
que les autorités ont bloqué le réseau
téléphonique et internet à khartoum et
dans d'autres villes les manifestants
continuent de réclamer un pouvoir civil
et des grenades lacrymogènes ont été
lancées par les forces de l'ordre qui
ont également tiré sur la foule elle
après des médecins présents sur place
quatre personnes auraient été tuées par
balles écoutez justement la réaction de
quelques bénéfices tant
on manifeste aujourd'hui pour la chute
du pouvoir militaire et contre l'accord
politique qui était censé mettre fin à
l'effusion de sang
mais malheureusement il ya encore des
morts et de la violence cela signifie
que cet accord n'est pas le bon
ma première demande c'est d'en finir
avec les militaires au pouvoir je ne
soutiens pas cet accord avec le premier
ministre car depuis le début signé la
déclaration constitutionnelle avec les
militaires était une erreur depuis le
début on n'aurait jamais dû faire
d'accord avec les militaires tout le
monde sait que m des ti et le général
abdel fattah le bourg ain sont des
hommes de l'ancien président el béchir
jusqu'à aujourd'hui aucun des objectifs
de la révolution n'a été atteint
la qualité de l'air est au centre de
nombreuses controverses à sofia et dont
les plus grandes villes de bulgarie l
union européenne vigilante concernant le
respect des normes ne cesse d'alerter
les autorités bulgares et depuis le
début du mois de décembre elles ont
effectué des centaines d'inspection à la
recherche de polluants atmosphériques
potentiel walid belani
dans la brume électrique au sein de la
capitale bulgare les voitures se
succèdent aux sons des pots
d'échappement
mais la ville au plus d'un million
d'habitants essaie de se racheter une
conscience verte en affrétant des bus
écologique sofia en effet été épinglé
pour ses niveaux élevés de pollution
atmosphérique
la chose la plus importante est que les
gens aient suffisamment de revenus pour
pouvoir s'offrir des automobiles
écologiques électriques hybrides c'est
ainsi que l'air deviendra plus propre
une eau douce
je pense que ce sont les voitures qui
détériorent le plus l'air est aussi
certaines maisons privées où sont
enterrés des objets qui ne doivent pas
être enterrée
la qualité de l'air une question à
laquelle sont confrontées judiciairement
les autorités bulgares en juin dernier
six citoyens appuyé par deux
organisations environnementales à but
non lucratif ainsi que greenpeace ont
intenté des recours pour dénoncer
notamment l'irresponsabilité de la
municipalité de sofia recours qui reste
pour l'heure en suspens à l'origine de
cet attentisme des tribunaux qui rejette
systématiquement les plaintes concernant
les niveaux de pollution
les habitants de sofia ville avec de
l'air pollué depuis plus de dix ans et
attendent un plan audacieux qui
résolvent enfin cette crise sanitaire et
réduisent les milliers de décès
prématurés liés à l'air pollué au lieu
de se concentrer sur un plan qui
débarrasserait le pays du dioxyde de
soufre toxiques le gouvernement bulgare
redoublent d'efforts pour maintenir en
vie les vieilles centrales polluantes
même en pleine procédure d'infraction de
la commission
cette situation menace directement la
santé de la population
une procédure d'infraction a été entamée
de la part de la commission européenne
cette dernière a condamné en effet pour
la première fois en 2010 est la bulgarie
pour avoir dépassé dans plusieurs
grandes villes du pays les valeurs
limites de concentration de particules
par jour et par année en juillet dernier
par exemple la commission européenne
ciblent également 113 des charges
abritant des déchets non conformes aux
législations
les autorités bulgares ont indiqué que
des mesures réparatrices sont en phase
préparatoire où seront mis en oeuvre à
partir de 2024 la mère de sophia quant à
elle mise sur l'installation de panneaux
solaires et une réglementation plus
stricte sur la circulation des voitures
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
vous d'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité dans un peu plus de trente
minutes reste avec nous sur arte france
à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
chacun pour soi dieu pour tous petits
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent pour la haine en soi
vient des lignes ont aujourd'hui on a
une gauche extrêmement sujet de maths et
la société
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview